hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game uh from round two of the
norway chess 2022 it's wesley saw versus
magnus carlsen and this is their
armageddon game so the classical game
ended in a draw it was a very uneventful
draw some 34 moves of basically nothing
they just traded pieces very quickly and
uh the the game ended in a draw and the
game didn't last for very long i think
uh the other players even commented on
how come they've ended the the game so
quickly uh but in armageddon uh anything
can always happen and
the games tend to be a bit more
interesting so let's see what happened
in this one as well
we could discuss uh
what happened
and we will after we check out the game
of course so wesley with the white
pieces opens with e4
which is different from the classical
game where they just went into a well
like i said an uneventful queen's gambit
declined so here we have e4 we have e5
by magnus knight f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to c4 now going for the italian
game
and magnus goes for knight to f6 he goes
for the two knights defense we have d3
and now bishop to c5 so the joko
pianissimo variation is on the board we
have bishop to g5 and h6 now challenging
the bishop bishop h4 we have d6 and now
c3 we have a6 and a4 so just a an entire
sea of theory will be explored here
before we
actually uh get get a glimpse of of new
territory so better back to a7 knight
beat the d2 and now queen uh to e7
developing the queen we have castles and
now magnus strikes in the center with
the g5 uh on the king side with g5
leaving his king in the center and
saying that okay maybe wesley castle a
little bit too soon but like i said this
is all been played before so
and no no problems there that's back to
g3 and now knight to h7 and here wesley
goes for b4 and it's very interesting
because this is a move uh alireza furuja
played against wesley so uh last year in
the in the grand chester's rapid paris
tournament and that game ended in a draw
so here wesley repeats the move while it
has a played against him and he wants to
further expand on the queen side here we
have knight to fade by magnus the knight
is now coming to g6 from there you will
have very nice access to f4 and h4
squares uh and in the game uh furuja vs
wesley f d4 was played but here wesley
plays b5 and it is now uh only as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how magnus deals with
this we have knights to 85
goes after the light square bishop
bishop to d5 and now c6 pushing the
bishop back we have bishop back to a2
and now magnus continues uh his uh
remaneuvering of the knight tonight to
g6 we have rook to b1 and here a
captures on b5 uh we have a captures on
b5 and now magnus plays c captures on b5
and this is a slight imprecision uh from
magnus g4 first is is better but okay c
captures we have rook captures now you
don't have time to play g4 because your
knight here is also hanging so knight to
c6 and now bishop to d5 by wesley and
now again magnus doesn't like a g4 but
he plays h5 and g4 right away again is
better than you have h5 h4 after h5 this
gives wesley enough time to play h3 and
now you will open up the position with
the g4 but the problem is this knight
now gets the h2 square which will be a
big deal here so g4 we have captures
captures and the knight to h2 now
attacking the g4 pawn knight to f4 now
saying okay you go after your your g4
pawn i'm going after the d3 pawn uh but
now we have pawn to d4 uh striking in
the center so now you can't capture
because the knight here is hanging uh
just a second i think meadow wants to
come in
yep it was him
so after d4 uh wesley has the sorry
magnus has the very nice knight to h5
now putting pressure on the bishop and
all of a sudden it's a magnus who's uh
who has a fine position here we have
knight to b3
and now comes knight to d8 here magnus
could capture right away there's nothing
wrong with that for example captures
captures queen to g5 but he wants to
re-maneuver the knight first knight to
d8 and now after wesley's rook to a5 now
he goes after knight captures and g3 f
captures and queen the g5 so this is
armageddon uh we are of course not going
to analyze it as deeply as the classical
games and the lines are not so so vast
as you know players don't have uh all
the time in the world to see what's
happening so here we have rook to e1
it's important to cover that e3 square
not allowing queen to e3 check now comes
knight back to c6 attacks the rook and
bishop characters we have b captures and
queen to a1 now now wesley is putting
pressure on the bishop here and what can
magnus do it seems like magnus is the
one who's attacking but there's just no
good way to attack that's the problem uh
so here uh luckily there's rook to b8
the knight on b3 is undefended so here
rook captures on a7 rook captures on b3
and now again queen to a2 very nicely
done by wesley uh attacking the rook and
if the rook moves of course queen
captures on f7 is coming unless the rook
moves to b7 which is the only move this
is what magnus plays
rook captures on b7 bishop captures and
now queen a7 attacking the bishop uh
bishop the c8 this is the only move and
now queen to c7 attacking the bishop the
d6 pawn the cease exponent here what can
magnus do there's only one good way to
avoid the catastrophe and that is just
the castle king side uh so now wesley
has um a choice he can capture here he
can capture here the rook now defends
the bishop so the bishop is safe but
wesley doesn't capture anything he says
my knight is doing nothing let's
remaneuver the knight and well as the
title suggests when there's a knight
there's a chance knight to f1 we have e
captures c captures and now queen to f6
so uh magnus now uh pretty much sold all
of his problems and if he can hold this
to a draw then he wins because in
armageddon if you get a draw you win the
game rook to d1 we have c5 now magnus
gives up a pawn
and he will just play bishop to e6 and
he will say there is no way for you to
break uh break open the position so we
have captures captures and captures and
now just bishop to e6 and wesley is up
upon but it's a double g pawning it's
very unlikely that you will be able to
uh to push for something here uh but
like i said and
that's what they say when there's a
knight there's a chance so wesley starts
with knight to e3 uh and okay rook the
c8 the magnus activates the rook we have
queen to d6 and now queen to g5
just attacking the knight here and it
seems like there's no good way for
wesley to continue pushing for a win
here but there is queen to f4 now it's
hard to say if you will actually win
this if magnus trades but you undoubled
your pawns and now you have you have
great chances at winning so of course
magnus doesn't want to allow this and
the only way at uh sort of keep the keep
the tension without uh losing right away
is to play f6 that's what you have to
play but that's not what magnus played
instead magnus played queen to c5 which
again makes sense you pinned the knight
everything is perfectly fine
however he missed a very very important
idea that wesley has so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
winning move for wesley while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that we
need to gain control over the g5 square
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show of course the move is
ponte e5 that's the good stuff if you've
spotted this then no doubt you are a
true true master of positional play and
uh you know other styles of play uh so
what can magnus do now now queen to g5
check is coming there's nothing he can
do about this but is that queen to g5
check enough for wesley to push for a
win well let's see what happens we rook
to a8 now magnus wants to get the rook
into the attack uh queen to g5 check and
now kink to h7 it doesn't matter you
could also go to f8 the
nothing really changes the rook is
coming to f1 and it's just going to be a
disgusting position to play but magnus
played king to h7 and now again king to
h2 unpinning but also in some crazy
lines imagine rook to h1 and then just
delivering checkmate with kink back to
g1 very very nice so magnus needs to do
something about this he plays rook to g8
puts pressure on the queen
queen to h4 with check we have king to
g7 and now not rushing rushing to to
just grab a pawn knight to f5 check
that's that's the way to uh to win this
now you have to you have to capture you
have to give up your bishop because well
whatever you do if king fade and rook to
d8 is checkmate the knight is covering
these squares and of course if you go up
the board then we just capture with
checking h7 queen to h5 will be
checkmate so here uh magnus has to
capture now comes queen to f6 check king
the h7 again if you go to f8 rook
delivers checkmate so that's out of the
question king to h7 and now queen
captures an f5 check uh we have king
back to g7 now queen to f6 anyways in
this position on move 50 that magnus
carlsen resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here he had some
three seconds on the clock uh but
whatever he does uh he just loses
because if you go back then rook to d8
ends the game and of course if king to
h7 then we pick up the f7 pawn and of
course you guys can already see that
this is winning we have an open position
of the king the rook can attack the pass
pawn is active uh for example rook g7
queen f5 check and if let's say king
here rook the d6 check
there are no more squares if this then
queen captures with checkmate your only
other option is to give up the queen but
of course this is completely winning for
wesley so yeah after queen to f6 check
magnus uh resigns and a very very nice
victory for wesley so uh in against the
two knights defense so magnus uh uh felt
felt very good when when he played this
bishop to e6 he gave up a pawn maybe uh
you know maybe too quickly but okay uh
it was it was definitely the way to go
because after bishop e6 there is not all
that much you can do but it's armageddon
uh he allowed that e5 move to happen and
after that there was just no saving the
position
uh so remember when there's a night
there's a way it's what they say uh i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to lucas wang and i would like to thank
andre theron alexander john juarez
valentina and ananda legend for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
norway chess tournament until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and as i forgot of course uh
here are the standings uh so you know
maybe you guys are interested in that as
well uh see you soon